[Applaudissements]
elle provoque la controverse
une fois de plus dans une série
documentaire qui sera diffusé en mars
sur la plateforme hulu hillary clinton
tire à boulet rouge sur hbo nissan 2
elle dit et je cite il était au congrès
pendant des années personne ne l'aiment
personne ne veut travailler avec lui il
n'a rien accompli
elle qualifie son rival de 2016 à la
primaire démocrate de politiciens de
carrière et dans une entrevue avec le
rallye woods doit porter hillary clinton
en rajoute
siboni scène deux affronté dans notre
homme cet automne à l'élection
présidentielle elle pourrait refuser de
l'appuyer
enders s'était pourtant ralliées à
clinton en 2016 après sa défaite contre
elle il avait participé à une
quarantaine d'événements de sa campagne
aujourd'hui l'ancien secrétaire d'état
est incapable de lui rendre la pareille
elle évoque une culture hostile autour
de saintes 2 hostile aux femmes
particulièrement
plus tôt ce mois ci c'était au tour
d'elizabeth warren de l'accusé de
sexisme la candidate à la primaire
démocrate affirme que le vétéran
politicien lui a confié en privé l'an
dernier qu'une femme ne pouvait
remporter la présidence bernis enders
nie en bloc
il est il faut le dire au coeur d'une
chaude lutte à deux semaines du caucus
de l'iowa premier arrêt officiel des
primaires
trois candidats ont une véritable chance
de l'emporter selon cet expert
surtout ce jour by the bunny 5 heures et
il a pété warden et l'a fait
effectivement que madame clinton nuit on
va dire ou dénonce ou un appui pauvre
nice 1-2
il est vrai que ça va rendre en corse
est le plus féroce d'ici les deux
prochaines semaines
elle a droit à son opinion
il faut que sonne plus méchant
le sénateur du vermont préfère pour le
moment comme ses collègues se concentrer
sur le procès en destitution du
président sommes ici sébastien
desrosiers radio canada montréal